regardez vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre et vous seuls et c'est voilà
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
donc je vais donc vous présenter la
programmation militaire avec le
calendrier qu'a indiqué le président
syrien qui aura pas les questions
aujourd'hui compromettra à une séance
ultérieure les questions ce qui vous
permettra il faudrait que ça nous permet
de respecter le calendrier des échéances
et aidera donc il faut qu'on fasse au
mieux à cet égard nous nous sommes dans
un moment de gravité je vais pas revenir
sur la discussion que nous avons eue à à
huit clos demain il y aura une session
extraordinaire du parlement
mais je crois que l'actualité met en
évidence une fois de plus la nécessité
de disposer d'une défense forte et de
moyens nous garantissant l'autonomie
stratégique appuyé en particulier sur
des capacités au au meilleur niveau et
c'est l'enjeu du projet de loi de
programmation militaire que j'ai
présenté au conseil des ministres le 2
août dernier et que je voudrais détaillé
avec vous aujourd'hui vous savez que ce
projet est la déclinaison concrète des
orientations que le président de la
république a approuvé le 29 avril
dernier à travers le livre blanc sur la
défense et la sécurité nationale et là
où le livre blanc fixer un cap sur 15
ans la loi définit un cadre précis et
annualisées pour l'évolution de nos
forces dans les six ans qui viennent
je voudrais
on tenir là pour l'introduction
sauf que j'ai noté comme vous que le
niveau des risques des menaces qui
pèsent sur la sécurité collective de la
france et de l'europe a fait l'objet de
réactions et de propos du président de
la république devant la conférence des
ambassadeurs etc il a rappelé à ce
moment là la nécessité de maintenir à un
bon niveau
notre effort de défense je voudrais tout
d'abord revenir sur le cadre financier
de cette programmation
les chiffres sont désormais connus ce
progrès ce projet de loi de
programmation maintient notre budget au
niveau actuel c'est-à-dire 31 milliards
4,2 recourant pendant trois ans dans un
deuxième temps entre 2016 et 2019
ce budget augmentera progressivement
pour atteindre 32 milliards 5,2 euros
courants et les crédits budgétaires
progresseront en valeur dès 2016 puis en
volume à compter de 2018 et les
ressources programmé sur la période 2014
2019 atteignent 1 690 milliards
exprimé en euros courants cet arbitrage
est une décision politique forte comme
le président l'a souligné le 13 juillet
lorsqu'il s'est adressé aux armées à
l'hôtel de brienne les crédits de la
défense seront j'assiste sur ce point
dit le président de la république
à la différence de la plupart des
ministères préserver dans leur intégrité
c'est un effort que la nation fait non
pas pour les armer mais pour sa propre
sécurité et il a repris les propos du
même type devant les ambassadeurs il y a
quelques jours
dans le même temps la défense consent un
effort significatif pour le redressement
des comptes publics
cet effort passe notamment par la
stabilisation des ressources programmée
entre 2014 et 2016 stabilisation qui
égale l'inflation et cet effort passe
aussi j'y reviendrai par une diminution
importante de nos effectifs
pour atteindre le niveau de ressources
que je viens d'évoquer mais aussi pour
que la défense participe au redressement
des comptes publics des ressources
exceptionnelles viennent compléter les
ressources budgétaires à hauteur de 6
milliards cent sur la période c'est à
dire 3 % des ressources totales
l'engagement du président de la
république a aussi porté sur la
transparence de nos choix dans le
domaine que je sais délicat des
ressources exceptionnelles
c'est pourquoi le rapport annexé au
projet de loi expose de façon précise la
différence ceux du précédent les
différentes origines de ces ressources
ambitieuse mais réaliste je les rappelle
brièvement il s'agit de l'intégrité
d'une intégralité pendant du produit de
cession d'emprise immobilière utilisé
par le nice à la défense il s'agit du
nouveau pays a financé par le produit de
cession des participations khroubis
public au profil l'excellence
technologique des industries de défense
il s'agit du produit de la mise aux
enchères de la bande de fréquence
comprise entre les fréquences 694 est de
590 michael et fréquence de très haute
valeur pour les opérateurs en raison de
ses caractéristiques techniques il
s'agit aussi des redevances versées par
les opérateurs privés au titre des
cessions de fréquences déjà réalisés
lors de la précédente loi de
programmation enfin il s'agit du produit
des cessions additionnelles des
participations d'entreprises publiques
qui se révélerait nécessaires pour
compléter ses moyens je précise
d'ailleurs à cet égard que pour le
projet de loi de finances 2014 il a été
fait appel à 3-3 ressources la fois les
ressources immobilières à la fois les
une partie des sessions de fréquences
déjà réalisés et la mobilisation pour un
milliard cinq milliards
le la mobilisation du pays acp mais
l'inventaire la déclinaison de
l'ensemble des ressources qui
permettront de mobilité d'être mobilisés
pour les ressources exceptionnelles que
j'ai indiqué nous permettent de garantir
l'ensemble du dispositif mais comme
j'avais écouté le sénat monsieur le
président et comme chacun admet que
l'évaluation du produit de cession est
par nature délicate
une clause de sauvegarde a été prévu
conformément à ce que vous aviez demandé
elle permettra de mobiliser d'autres
ressorts exceptionnel si le produit ou
le financement de celles que je viens
d'évoquer s'avère insuffisant et c'est
une garantie supplémentaire pour la
défense en sens inverse si le montant
des ressources disponibles devaient
excéder les 6 milliard cent millions
les 6 milliards sont prévus la défense
pourrait en bénéficier à hauteur d'un
petit milliard 900 millions d'euros
supplémentaires c'est ainsi que les
annotations sont décidés concernant le
cadre financier de cette programmation
je voudrais ajouter quelques mots sur le
financement des opérations extérieures
une dotation au prévisionnel annuel de
450 millions d'euros figurent désormais
dans le budget de la mission défense en
adéquation avec des priorités
stratégiques et le nouveau contrat
opérationnel défini dans le livre blanc
cette dotation est un peu inférieur à la
précédente mais il s'agit de tenir
compte de la nouvelle définition nos
contrats opérationnels qui n'est pas
celle de livre blanc de la programmation
précédente là encore et conformément à
ce que vous aviez souhaité aussi sur ce
point une clause de sauvegarde a été
mise en place
l'enjeu est de garantir la soutenabilité
budgétaire d'éventuelles décisions
l'engagement militaire de la france ces
décisions relevant du chef de l'état et
de l'ensemble du gouvernement il est
précisé dans des termes voisins à cela
la loi précédente que les surcoûts
résultants soit nouvelle opération soit
du renforcement des opérations
existantes en 2013 serait couvert par un
financement interministériel adopte donc
on a pu faire aboutir des observations
que vous aviez avec la nombreuses
reprises évoqué et j'en suis
particulièrement satisfaite
vous le voyez nous avons voulu garantir
à notre défense un niveau de ressources
ambitieux et réaliste à la fois
ambitieux par la trajectoire que le
président la réplique arrêté réaliste
par les différentes assurances que nous
avons voulu prendre en diversifiant les
ressources il en élaborant plusieurs
mécanismes de sauvegarde pour garantir
in fine est la sincérité de cette
programmation et c'était le voeu que
vous aviez vous même formule
pour en revenir maintenant à une
perspective plus large mais évidemment
en lien avec la sanctuarisation
budgétaire que je viens d'évoquer
je voudrais souligner combien ce projet
de loi de programmation est celui du
maintien de notre rang stratégique
l'ambition du gouvernement s'énonce
clairement
garantir à la france sa capacité à
intervenir dans l'ensemble des
situations où ses intérêts de sécurité
ses responsabilités internationales
pourrait être mise en jeu grâce au
niveau de ressources que je viens
d'évoquer
nous resterons l'un des rares pays dans
le monde à pouvoir assurer simultanément
les trois missions fondamentales que
sont la protection du territoire et la
population
la dissuasion nucléaire appuyez sur les
deux composantes distinctes et
complémentaires et l'intervention sur
des théâtres extérieurs pour des
missions aussi bien de gestion de crise
que de guerre je ne reviens pas ici sur
le détail de l'ambition politique portée
par le livre blanc est désormais connue
mais je voudrais insister à ce moment
sur la manière dont cette ambition se
décline
concrètement dans le projet de lpm la
répartition des crédits traduit les
priorités que le président de la
république a signé notre défense
j'en évoquerez 2 la préparation
opérationnelle et l'équipement des
forces pour la préparation
opérationnelle
nous reconnaissons tous que sans cette
préparation
sans une préparation opérationnelle
efficace est suffisante
nous ne saurions disposer de capacités
militaires ni d'armée professionnels
crédible la valeur des hommes et des
femmes de la défense qui a plusieurs
fois trouvé à s'exprimer dans ces
derniers mois en découlent directement
et vous savez pas ce que j'ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises devant votre
commission que cette la une de mes
préoccupations personnelles
depuis mon entrée en fonction j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous le dire à plusieurs
reprises
depuis 2011 2012 en particulier nous
observons un fléchissement des activités
opérationnelles et ce fléchissement peut
s'expliquer de diverses manières
l'épuisement des stocks dans lesquels
nos armées ont puisé ces dernières
années sans que le financement de leurs
compléments ne soit prévu le
vieillissement des parcs mais aussi
l'arrivée de mattel nouvelle génération
dont le coût d'utilisation et
d'entretien est considérable en plus
élevé et tout cela se cumulent et de
façon générale le contexte financier a
pesé sur l'activité sur l'entraînement
alors qu'ils revêtent pour ma part un
caractère prioritaire parce que cette
évolution n'est pas acceptable
nous avons parce que la tendance sont
plus ce n'est pas acceptable
nous avons cherché à maintenir puis à
redresser progressivement le niveau de
préparation opérationnelle dans ce
projet de lpm sur la période 2014 2015
les efforts conduits permettront
d'obtenir une stabilité globale de
l'activité à un niveau comparable à
celui de 2013 et ensuite nous
travaillerons à relever les taux
d'activité et cette priorité accordée à
l'entraînement de nos forces se traduit
par un effort financier conséquent
ainsi les crédits consacrés à
l'entretien programmé des matériels
progression en moyenne de 4 3% par an en
valeur pour s'établir à un niveau moyen
de 3 milliards 4 courant par an sur la
période
sur l'ensemble de la période contre 2
milliards 9 à la loi de finances
initiale de 2013 donc s'agit là d'un
effort significatif
la facilité et souvent de renier là
parce que c'est moins spectacle c'est
moins spectaculaire
c'est moins flambant et n'est par contre
c'est l'essentiel
et si on veut avoir des forces en étal
d'activité de réactivité il faut donner
à l'activité opérationnelle une priorité
c'est ce que j'ai fait et 3 qui
permettra de revenir à un effort
suffisamment performants dans le domaine
des équipements
je veux d'abord souligner l'effort
conséquent qui va être réalisée puisque
ce projet de loi de programmation
prévoit que les crédits d'équipement
soit en hausse constante au cours de la
période 2014 2019 en 2013
16 milliards d'euros ont été consacrés
aux équipements et ce montant sera en
constante progression pour atteindre 18
milliards de en 2019
grâce à ce niveau de crédit
le renouvellement de nos équipements
sera assuré notre base industrielle
préservés conformément aux principes de
la stratégie militaire exposées dans le
livre blanc vous me permettrez de les
rappeler ici car ces quatre principes
sont au fondement des choix
d'équipements qui figurent dans cette
loi de programmation militaire
premier principe préserver notre
autonomie stratégique et ce projet de
loi prévoit d'abord de garantir la
pérennité de la dissuasion la livraison
du m51 points 2 la mise en service du
laser mégajoule le lancement des travaux
d'élaboration du futur snl de troisième
génération ou encore dans le domaine du
renseignement
le lancement du satellite crs
entièrement développé dans cette période
pour un lancement en 2010 neuf tout cela
contribuera directement et ce sont des
décisions lourdes
toujours pour satisfaire cette exigence
d'autonomie stratégique nous
renforcerons les capacités permettant de
prendre l'initiative dans les opérations
qu'il s'agisse du renseignement avec la
livraison de deux satellites du système
musis sso et de drone mâle et de drones
tactiques ici dans le même domaine nous
assurerons le
renforcement de nos forces spéciales où
nous renforcerons aussi les capacités
qui sont engagés au contact de l'ennemi
ce sont ici les programmes rafale freine
missiles mmp et scorpions enfin nous
consoliderons notre capacité à fédérer
et entraîner nos alliés au sein d'une
coalition
pour ce faire nous développerons
notamment nos moyens de frappes précises
dans la profondeur avec la livraison de
deux cent cinquante missiles de
croisière l'arrivée du missile de
croisière naval et la révision du scalp
à mi parcours
ainsi notre attitude a planifié entré en
premier sur un théâtre de guerre sera
rassuré deuxième principe pour garantir
la cohérence du modèle avec la diversité
des missions dans lesquelles la france
est susceptible d'engager ses forces
armées
ce projet de loi de programmation
prévoit différé différents types
d'équipements premièrement pour répondre
aux menaces d'emploi de la force par des
états il a des programmes liés à la
dissuasion que je viens d'évoquer les
frais mécénat les avions rafale
lancement de la rénovation du char
leclerc l'équipement et nage 90 et
l'adaptation du cul du tigre toujours
pour assurer la cohérence et pour
conduire la durée dans la durée les
opérations de gestion de crise ce projet
de lpm prévoit la prolongation des
mirage 2000
la rénovation des frégate légère furtive
et le remplacement de novea b comme de
noah mix 30 10 rc nos forces auront
ainsi les moyens adaptés de conduire ces
opérations qui sont récurrentes l'anc
exigeante
troisièmement toujours au titre de la
cohérence du deuxième principe de nos
fondamentaux au titre de la cohérence du
modèle le programme est ce qu a et
plusieurs programmes de moyens navals de
surveillance et d'intervention ainsi que
des investissements dans le domaine nbc
renforcement renforcerons nos capacités
de protection du pays étaient à sec ses
intérêts de sécurité
troisième principe le principe de
différenciation qui conduit à distinguer
les forces et leurs entraînements en
fonction des missions qu'elles seront
appelées à à remplir on distinguera les
forces de dissuasion
les forces de protection
sion force de gestion de crise et des
force de coercition les forces
terrestres seront ainsi organisés en
brigades adapté aux brigades lourdes
adapté en premier qui seront notamment
équipé de chars leclerc et devait
baisser il y aura deux brigades lourdes
adapter l entrée en premier trois
brigades multi rôles destinés à la
gestion de crise avec des v abe et les
premiers bébés est maire et de brigade
légère adapté à l'action d'urgence dans
le domaine naval les capacités de combat
pour les opérations de haute intensité
c'est toujours dans la différenciation
se verront renforcées par les six
premières fremm le premier et senna de
type barracuda ainsi que par la
rénovation des frégates active auquel
j'ai fait allusion tout à l'heure en
parallèle l'armement de nouveaux
patrouilleurs et la transformation des
avions de surveillance contribuera à
renouveler notre attitude au contrôle à
l'intervention dans de vastes espaces
maritimes qu'il s'agit de nos propres
côtes ou bien de l'outre-mer concernant
les forces aériennes enfin la livraison
de 26 rafale supplémentaires et
l'arrivée des a400m et mrtt renforceront
leurs capacités dans l'hypothèse d'un
conflit majeur s'efforce conserveront
par ailleurs un nombre d'aéronefs
suffisants grâce au prolongement
d'avions plus anciens à l'instar des
mirage 2000 notamment pour remplir les
missions de gestion de crise et de
protection de l'espace aérien national
on sera là dans le sur la trajectoire
nous permettant d'avoir le parc 225
avions en ligne en 2025 ce qui est
l'objectif du livre blanc et nous sommes
dans la déclinaison de cette de cet
itinéraire quatrième principe la
mutualisation enfin qui consiste en
premier lieu affecter un noyau de
capacités polyvalent terreur à plusieurs
missions
elle a ainsi contribué au choix
d'équipement en permettant de définir
des cibles pour les rafale et mer
étaient laissées dans les fremm doté de
capacités anti sous marine ou encore les
missiles de croisière naval ses
capacités sont en effet multimissions
mais la mutualisation peut et doit
s'entendre à une autre échelle dans le
cadre d'une relance ce pragmatique de
l'europe de la défense
ce principe nous incite en effet
envisager ensemble certaines capacités
critiques et c'est pour cette raison que
le projet de loi d'une part préserve
tous les grands programmes conduits en
coopération que soit fremm à 400m tic en
h 90 milles 6 ou santé et d'autre part
lens plusieurs autres programmes dont on
peut citer la nll antinavire léger dont
on a beaucoup parlé en commissions déjà
où le système de lutte antimines futur
le slam ce qui est prévu à la fin de la
loi de programmation militaire dans le
domaine du renseignement enfin un
principe majeur d'économie de
coordination impose la mutualisation de
certaines capacités techniques entre nos
services
si un ajustement du calendrier des
programmes est nécessaire compte tenu
des contraintes financières
l'effort consenti pour l'équipement des
forces qui s'élève à 10 7 milliards cent
en moyenne annuelle sur l'ensemble de la
période
pour 16 milliards en 2013 je le rappelle
cet effort est donc particulièrement
significatif et le tour rapide d'horizon
des programmes que je vienne faire en
prenant les quatre rubriques fondamental
pour les décrire pour éviter qu avec un
catalogue qui aurait été ennuyeux ce
tour d'horizon est là pour en témoigner
cet effort en matière d'équipement et
s'appliquant à nos forces bénéficie
aussi un aux industries de défense et je
vais en parler
l'exigence de sincérité sans laquelle il
n'est pas de programmation crédible
m'incite à tenir comme pour le livre
blanc un discours de vérité
cette programmation est ambitieux je les
dis elle n'en sera pas moins difficile
les efforts qui figure dans le projet de
loi s'entendent dans un double sens
effort de la nation pour sa propre
sécurité et fort de la défense pour le
redressement des comptes publics
s'il ya donc des priorités j'en ai
évoqué lequel de quelques-unes
il y a aussi remercié le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs des
mesures d'économies qui rendent crédible
la programmation que nous présentons
dans le contexte financier à
tu es sur le plan budgétaire d'abord je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure je n'insiste
pas la reconduite du budget en valeur
jusqu'en 2016 constitue de fait un
effort conséquent ce n'était pas là
programme la progression prévue par mes
prédécesseurs mais je crois savoir
souligné lors d'auditions précédente
combien cette progression était devenu
irréaliste à partir du moment où la
crise de 2007/2008 intervenait
concernant les ressources humaines vous
le savez également la déflation des
effectifs va devoir se poursuivre en
cohérence avec les contraintes
financières et le nouvel modèle d'armée
porté par le livre blanc 10175 emplois
vont être supprimés au titre de la
précédente programmation avec 3500 le
seront au titre de la présente
lp m la définition de cette déflation sa
répartition au sein du ministère sera
guidée par trois priorités d'abord je
dis avec beaucoup de force parce que ont
tendance à sous-estimer ce propos
d'abord préserver les forces
opérationnelles et le soutien
opérationnel et les forces de combat ne
supporteront donc qu environ un tiers
des déflations d'effectifs nouvelles
envisagées
deuxième priorité maîtriser la masse
salariale vous savez que c'est un enjeu
de crédibilité majeur pour notre
ministère dans nos conversations avec
bercy dans nos discussions
interministérielles et j'entends que
nous soyons à la hauteur
le taux d'encadrement va donc diminuer
après cinq années qui l'ont vu croître
significativement
cet effort de des pyramides âge se
traduira par des réductions touchant le
nombre d'officiers sur la période 2014
enfin dernière priorité amorceront un
rééquilibrage des effectifs globaux du
ministère au profit du personnel civil
dans les secteurs non opérationnels je
mesure bien le prix de ces nouvelles
réductions après celle que le ministère
a déjà connu
j'ai donc tenu à ce qu'un nouvel esprit
inspirent les évolutions à venir sur la
base d'une analyse attentive est proche
la valeur que les hommes et les femmes
défense monte au quotidien les honore
mais aussi nous oblige parce que leur
engagement poehl jusqu'où le sacrifice
ultime
nous leur devons le plus grand respect
et ce respect doit inspirer chacun des
aspects de notre politique de ressources
humaines et c'est pour moi une
préoccupation que je continuerai à
suivre personnellement
concrètement pour conduire cette partie
difficile du projet de loi de
programmation militaire
ce projet de loi prévoit d'abord un
large plan de mesures d'accompagnement
des personnels appelés à quitter le
service
ce plan reposera sur trois leviers le
renforcement de la politique de
reconversion pour le personnel militaire
leur classement dans les fonctions
publiques et l'aide à la mobilité
externe pour les agents du ministère des
outils financiers d'incitation au départ
et à la mobilité comme porteront sur 933
millions d'euros sur la durée de la
programmation quatre mesures seront
proposées en particulier aux personnels
militaires la promotion fonctionnelle la
pension afférentes au grade supérieur
le pécule d'incitation aux départs et la
disponibilité rénover une parleront lors
de la discussion qui interviendra de
détail de ces mesures que j'ai pas
souhaité évoquer dans mon propos
introductif il n'y aura donc ni
dégagement de cadres ni mesures brutales
la déflation des effectifs sera obtenue
par les départs naturels
les départs inciter et un ajustement des
recrutements précise que l'impact sur
ces derniers étant limité au maximum
pour tenir compte des impératifs
opérationnels j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui réclame un personnel jeune
est physiquement apte au delà même de ce
plan d'accompagnement il faudra suivre
une méthode à laquelle j'attache
beaucoup de prix celle de l'ecoute celle
de la concertation et celle de l'analyse
fonctionnelle
le ministère a trop connu de réforme
appliquée de manière rapide et brutale
pour qu'il puisse envisager cette
déflation de la même manière au
contraire je veux prendre du temps je
veux une table de concertation des
coudes analyse fonctionnelle avant
chaque réduction
ce conte fonctionnel c'est le contraire
de l'action et la coupe mathématiques uw
arithmétique et j'ai confié au
secrétaire général pour l'administration
au directeur des ressources humaines en
lien avec des états majeurs cette
mission particulière pour que nous ayons
un modèle simplifié cohérent mais qu'ils
soient mises en oeuvre avec la tension
qu'il convient de la même façon le
dialogue et la concertation doivent
permettre de faire émerger des
évolutions positives de la condition du
personnel de la condition militaire en
particulier celles ci le rapport annexé
dénonce avec force est à mes yeux un
élément constitutif de la capacité
opérationnelle elle même de nos armées
un plan ministériel prévu dans la
programmation et j'ai insisté pour que
ce soit inscrit dans la programmation
permettra d'établir et de financer des
pistes de facilitation sur ce sujet en
particulier dans le domaine du logement
de l'aide sociale et de soutien familial
sur les restructurations qui découlent
de ces déflation d'effectifs j'aurai la
même méthode associant l'analyse
l'écoutent la concertation il a encore
je veux prendre le temps pour ce qui
concerne l'airé structuration de l'année
1900 de me donne l'année 2014 qui sont
pour la plupart liés à la précédente
programmation nous annoncerons les sites
concernés
à la fin de ce mois au début du mois
prochain en matière de restructuration
je connais toute l'importance du
dialogue avec les élus la tête du
ministère la défense je n'oublie pas que
j'ai eu une vie antérieure d'élu local
que j'ai subi dans le passé dans la
ville que j'avais l'honneur de diriger
de restructurations successives et je
sais tu passage m'a permis des
réflexions et je serais tout à fait
attentif au dialogue avec les élus pour
la mise en oeuvre des mesures
d'accompagnement nécessaires pour nous
l'objectif est de préserver au maximum
les liens qui unissent les harnais et
les territoires j'aurai donc une
attention toute particulière à ce que la
défense reste
la mesure du possible largement
présentes sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
mais notre objectif est aussi pour les
sites qui seront relativement peu
nombreux que nous serons amenés à fermer
de permettre une transition dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
j'avancerais en tout cas avec le souci
constant du contexte territorial et
contexte économique et social des
mesures qui seront décidées à cette fin
un accompagnement économique est prévue
par ce projet de la programmation
militaire
cet accompagnement tire les
enseignements des précédentes de
restructuration et notamment du risque
d'éparpillement des fonds publics est
désormais les actions de l'état seront
davantage concentrée recentrée sur un
nombre limité d'action parmi les plus
efficaces pour la redynamisation des
bassins d'emploi concernés 150 millions
d'euros seront au total consacré à
l'accompagnement économique des
territoires les plus affectées je
voudrais enfin souligné combien ce
projet de loi de programmation militaire
au delà des éléments que j'ai déjà
évoqué se consacre à la préparation de
l'avenir en permettant l'adaptation de
nos larmes et d'aujourd'hui aux guerres
de demain
ça fait quand même longtemps longtemps
je parle heures
c'est pour moi l'occasion d'évoquer
notre politique industrielle de défense
les chiffres sont connus mais on gagne à
les rappeler 4000 entreprises dont une
majorité de pme et de 10 165 mille
emplois directs qui sont autant
d'emplois hautement qualifiés donc peu
délocalisables un chiffre d'affaires
global de 15 milliards d'euros dans 30 à
40 % réalisés à l'exportation pour la
france c'est un outil exceptionnel
d'abord parce que notre industrie de
défense concours à notre autonomie
stratégique
on peut d'ailleurs raisonnablement
considérer que derrière chaque succès
des armes de la france comme tout
récemment au mali il ya des réussites
technologiques et industrielles préparer
nos futurs engagements c'est donc aussi
s'assurer que nous pourrons disposer des
équipements au meilleur niveau mais
notre industrie de défense concours
aussi au dynamisme de notre économie à
cet égard c'est l'une des premières du
monde comme les grands contrats obtenus
récemment encore aux émirats viennent de
le rappeler et elle doit demeurer dans
cette dynamique-là c'est pour merci
c'est pour cet ensemble de raisons que
l'industrie de défense est au coeur du
projet de loi de programmation les
crédits consacrés à l'investissement et
à l'équipement au profit de nos forces
qui seront comme je voulais faire depuis
17 milliards d'euros en moyenne annuelle
sur les six ans à venir concernent
chacun des neuf secteurs majeurs de
l'industrie de défense en matière de
préparation de l'avenir
l'ambition dont vont aussi bénéficier
nos industries défense concerne le
maintien d'un effort substantiel de
recherche et technologie
il s'agit là d'un objectif majeur et
d'une de mes préoccupations aussi
personnelle et nous maintiendrons des
crédits consacrés aux études amont plus
de 730 millions d'euros en moyenne
annuelle sur la période 2014 2019
donc en hausse par rapport à la période
précédente
ces crédits d'études amont bénéficieront
au renouvellement de composantes de la
dissuasion à l'avenir de l'aéronautique
de combat lutte sous marine et dans le
domaine terrestre à la poursuite des
efforts sur la protection des véhicules
et des équipages des combattants mais
aussi aux renseignements et à la montée
en puissance
de la cyberdéfense ou encore l'espace
pour ne citer que quelques exemples
d'une façon générale les forts de la
coopération avec la recherche civile
sera poursuivie notamment par
l'augmentation du soutien aux pme pmi
eti innovantes que permet le pacte
défense pme et de la même perspective le
dispositif rapid régime d'appui aux pme
pour l'innovation dural sera pérennisée
et renforcé avec 50 millions d'euros par
an contre 40 millions d'euros en 2013
la préparation de l'avenir c'est aussi
l'évolution du cadre juridique de notre
défense il me faut dire à ce moment
quelques mots des novations normative
contenues dans ce projet de loi de
programmation
d'autant plus que plusieurs sont
particulièrement importantes
j'insisterai particulièrement sur trois
domaines pour lesquels le projet de loi
ils doivent réellement d'une part en
adaptant le droit aux défis
d'aujourd'hui et d'autre part en le
préparant à ceux de demain dans le
domaine du renseignement d'abord le
projet loi renforce autant que le
permettait la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel sur la séparation du
pouvoir renforce le rôle et les
prérogatives de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
ce contrôle accru permettra d'ouvrir ou
de sécuriser certains dispositifs de
collecte de données et de consultation
des fichiers existants qui sont offerts
aux services de renseignement il ya donc
un ouverture plus large des possibilités
d'intervention des services de
renseignements mais en même temps un
contrôle accru parlementaire ce qui me
paraît un bon équilibre ses services de
renseignement en effet besoin d'avoir
accès à une information riche et
diversifié pour repérer les signaux
faibles est détecté suffisamment tôt les
risques notamment terroristes et plus
généralement tous les risques d'
atteinte à nos intérêts fondamentaux
le projet de loi innove aussi dans le
domaine de la cyber défense sont
précisés pour la première fois les
obligations que l'état peut imposer aux
autres
acteur d'importance vitale pour la
france en matière de sécurisation de
leur système d'information pour la
première fois aussi le droit prend en
compte les besoins des services de
l'état de défendre efficacement les
systèmes d'information les plus
sensibles contre les attaques
informatiques y compris par des procédés
qui s'il ne répondait pas cet objectif
légitime de préservation de la sécurité
nationale serait pénalement
répréhensible et le projet de loi permet
l'ensemble de ces avancées pour notre
propre sécurité
enfin comme le président de la
république l'avait expressément demandé
le projet de loi met en place divers
outils juridiques permettant une
judiciarisation inutile de l'action des
militaires en partance en vendant
d'éviter une judiciarisation inutile de
l'action des militaires engagés en
opération extérieure
l'objectif n'est pas de consacrer une
quelconque immunité pénale au profit des
militaires qu'il s'agisse du
commandement où des hommes et des femmes
durant il s'agit plus simplement de
faire prendre en compte par le droit
pénal la réalité de ce qu'est un conflit
armé
il s'agit de trouver un compromis entre
un droit pénal d'exception qu'est celui
du temps de guerre qui n'a heureusement
plus servi en france depuis le dernier
conflit mondial et le droit commun qui
est adapté au temps de paix sur certains
aspects ce droit commun peut en effet
être décalage voire franchement inadapté
aux réalités des conflits dans lesquels
nos militaires sont engagés et sont
prêts à donner leur vie comme d'ailleurs
à donner la mort serait amené sans doute
dans la discussion qui interviendra
commenter l'ensemble de ces nouveaux
textes qui s'intègre dans la loi de
programmation militaire qui sont tout à
fait significatif
je veillerai par ailleurs mais cela
n'avait pas sa place dans le projet de
loi lui-même à ce que les mécanismes
d'information d'accompagnement et
d'animation des familles des militaires
blessés ou tués au combat soit encore
améliorer la préparation de l'avenir
c'est également la réorganisation du
ministère c'est à dire la réforme de sa
gouvernance qui fait l'objet d'une
clarification une simplification et la
modernisation avec le regroupement des
états-majors directions et services
centraux sur le site de balard
l'enjeu est plurielle outre la
rationalisation des effectifs de
l'administration centrale et
l'optimisation du coût du soutien
il devrait résulter de ces évolutions
une amélioration de la gouvernance du
ministère et une modernisation des
conditions de travail des agents du
ministère civils et militaires la
préparation de l'avenir c'est encore
l'effort particulier que nous consentons
dans le domaine de la cyber défense et
du renseignement
au delà des programmes il convient de
relever que ce projet loi prend en
compte cette nouvelle donne stratégique
qu'est la cyber défense en la matière il
prévoit je les dis une adaptation notre
droit mais aussi le renforcement de nos
capacités
la mise en place d'une organisation
d'une chaîne opérationnelle centralisée
ainsi qu'un effort important en termes
d'études amont le renseignement est une
autre priorité conformément au livre
blanc aux engagements du président de la
république est déjà cité des moyens
nouveaux dont nous disposons en la
matière j'ai cité en particulier au
niveau satellitaire au niveau des drones
mais j'ai cité aussi le contrôle
parlementaire renforcer la préparation
de l'avenir
c'est enfin le renforcement du lien
armée nation
l'enjeu de ce renforcement c'est à la
fois la cohésion nationale l'adhésion la
nation à la politique de défense mais
également la reconnaissance du métier d
âme
le recrutement et la résilience des
populations face aux crises plusieurs
actions vont être ici mené dans le cas
de cette programmation elle concerne la
réserve militaire dans ses deux
composantes opérationnel et citoyenne
concerne aussi une rénovation du
parcours de citoyenneté avec notamment
une réflexion qui est actuellement
engagée sur la journée défense et
citoyenneté
mais l'association plus étroite de la
représentation nationale aux décisions
qui concernent la politique de défense
relève aussi de ce lien entre l'armée et
la nation que nous devons promouvoir le
renforcement de l'information des élus
en ce qui concerne notamment le suivi
des dotations financières des opérations
extérieures ou encore des exportations
d'armements et pour nous et pour moi en
particulier un objectif permanent je
crois on n'a pas fait la démonstration
au cours de l'année qui vient de se
passer je passerai d'ailleurs devant
devant vous de nouveau dans les
prochains jours
d'abord pour répondre aux questions de
cet exposé mais aussi pour représenter
le rapport annuel au parlement sur les
exportations d'armement
je voudrais conclure mon propos un peu
long en disant que l'exécution un peu
heurté de la précédente lpm en raison
des évolutions économiques et
financières a démontré la nécessité de
prévoir un dispositif de suivi et
d'actualisation de la lpm comme du livre
blanc tailleur l'exécution de la
présente lpn fera donc l'objet d'un
suivi annuel au niveau du conseil de
défense n'est pas présente dans le
public un rapport annuel d'exécution
sera également transmis aux commissions
compétentes du parlement
dans la même logique une première
actualisation de la lpm devra avoir lieu
fin 2015
elle permettra notamment de faire le
point sur l'activité opérationnelle sur
les équipements majeurs sur la déflation
d'effective et sur la mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble des réformes suivie d'un
débat
évidemment au bout de quatre ans la
présente lpn ne sera donc révisé pour
conduire à l'élaboration d'une nouvelle
loi de programmation
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs dans ses grandes
lignes le cadre fixé par ce projet de
loi programmation militaire
c'est un cadre et qui vivrait car nous
avons eu le souci constant d'une
répartition équitable de l'effort entre
les trois armées et au delà entre les
différentes entités du nhs
mystère pour le dire en un mot ce cadre
est le bon parce qu'il va nous permettre
d'adapter nos armées d'aujourd'hui aux
menaces de demain dans un contexte qui
rendait particulièrement difficile ce
travail essentiel nous l'avons menée je
crois et je pense que nous pouvons être
fiers du projet que je vous propose
aujourd'hui ce projet de lpm est
l'aboutissement d'un travail de
plusieurs mois qui a réuni les états
majeurs la dg alésia et l'ensemble des
services du ministère dans une réflexion
commune
il est aussi pour une partie de ses
orientations issues des travaux menés
par votre commission et dans le détail
des choix vous pourrez sans doute vous
reconnaître dans vos propositions
nous avons surtout élaborer ce projet en
ne cessant de penser à l'opération
serval qui se déroulait en même temps
que l'adoration et que les choix que
j'étais amené à faire qui se déroulait
de manière très professionnelle et qui a
conduit au résultat que vous connaissez
c'était dans la même période
le dégagement progressif d'afghanistan
dont nous avons toujours gardé à
l'esprit
hautmont la préparation de ce texte la
raison d'être notre défense et
l'engagement de celles et de ceux qui la
servent aussi bien et je forme le voeu
qu'une même pensé guident nos débats cet
automne pour cet enjeu essentiel pour la
sécurité de notre pays je vous remercie
de votre attention je serai à votre
disposition pour répondre à l'ensemble
de vos remarques lors de la prochaine
réunion
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
on vous lâche tout de suite où vous avez
ces minutes
non mais dites moi ça mais enfin cinq
minutes cinq minutes de bon moi je
voudrais tout d'abord on a duré
longtemps sur la première partie fruits
je sais je sais je sais mais j'ai vu des
gens non mais je pense que la première
partie était tellement nécessaire est
tellement importante que tout le monde
de comprendre à bien que c'est une
première pour notre commission n'a
jamais eu un débat de cette nature et de
cette richesse et d'ailleurs je tiens à
remercier toutes les composantes de la
commission pour la qualité de ses débats
qui deviendra public demain
que tout le monde le comprenne la
deuxième chose pour cette présentation
je voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
ministre je n'ai pas d'habitude moi de
présider une commission c'est la
première fois et bien évidemment je le
fais avec
avec tous mes collègues mais je vous
assure que je suis excessivement
satisfait de la manière dont votre
ministère prend en compte les travaux
préparatoires de la commission et tout
ce qui est fait par les binômes que l'on
désigne ont alors tout n'est pas
absolument parfait on l'aura des
questions à vous poser
on aura encore quelques précisions à
vous demander mais je vous assure que
nous nous retrouvons vraiment dans
l'esprit et dans la lettre de ce que
vous venez de nous présenter
néanmoins j'ai un de mes amis de la
commission qui en est un des
vice-présidents qui avait levé le doigt
presque au début de votre présentation
je ne peux pas résister à l'envié de lui
permettre de poser cette question
il s'agit de daniel rieder c'est très
privilégié là
mais au jeu je vais m'en tenir à une
question simple parce que naturellement
nous avions omis il avait enfin osé
aller voir et on le traitera
naturellement la question est la
suivante
compte tenu des contraintes néanmoins
dans lesquelles va s'exercer cette loi
de programmation militaire
est-ce que vous avez dès à présent
identifiés au regard de ce qui était des
lacunes capacitaire clairement exposé
mesuré dans les derniers conflits ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les points de
grande vigilance dans le en particulier
dans les trois premières années de ckoi
de programmation d'hiver voilà les
points de grande vigilance sur lesquels
naturellement vous comme nous nous
allons porter une attention extrême pas
démantibulé ou démolir le binôme je vais
demander à jacques gauthier s'il a un
complément ou une question c'est le sont
les deux seuls que je pourrais pas
surtout ne reprenons pas mal merci
monsieur bourges est à dire qu on aura
beaucoup de questions posées au ministre
dans un échange de coups plus complet la
prochaine fois non moi je voudrais
reprend des trois éléments qui pour moi
sont essentiels et nous ferons tout pour
aller au delà ce que vous nous avez
donné comme assurance c'est la garantie
des ressources exceptionnelles il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à les inscrire
dans le marbre
c'est cette clause de rendez-vous qui
nous permettra de nous adapter et nous
l'avions demandée par ailleurs et puis
aussi si ce retour à meilleure fortune
que nous voulons voir encadré et
garantie vous nous l'avez dit mais
sachez qu on sera très vigilant sur ce
point particulier monsieur le ministre
nous a tous maintenant mais je voudrais
dire d'abord à monsieur gautier que les
propos je vais tenir mais le texte de
loi lui-même correspond complètement à
tout ce que je vous ai dit au cours de
l'année sur mes engagements
y compris la partie vigilance y compris
la clause de sauvegarde qu'au départ je
n'imaginais pas possible de pouvoir
inscrire dans la loi
bon tout cela correspond à propos j'ai
tenu et est en parfaite cohérence avec
des propos tenus par la commission que
de du sénat je dois dire aussi que ces
dirigeants s'imposera il faudra surtout
faire en sorte que en 2016
on passe les étapes pour que vous
appelez retour à meilleure fortune mais
c'est aussi dans ce texte de loi y
compris le passage à une première
augmentation puis dernière augmentation
de 1 en 2010 obsession que celle tout à
fait mais l'ensemble du dispositif et
fed
je pense ficelé de telle sorte que ça se
dérouler là devraient de fraises se
faire j'ai entendu beaucoup
d'interrogations sur les ressources
exceptionnelles il y compris l'année
dernière ils ont eu lieu et elle était
là cette année elles sont là donc j'ai
pas de raison de ne pas croire
j'espère que vous non plus qu'ils ne
seront pas là pour les prochaines
échéances même si il faut être très
vigilant
je suis bien placé pour le savoir sur la
question du renner tout à l'heure
j'essaie de réfléchir en vous écoutant
il ya une chose qui est certaine pour
moi c'est le la préparation
opérationnelle
il faut pas
faut pas mégoter sur le sujet ce n'est
pas une variable d'ajustement
et c'est une tentation donc faut une
grande vigilance sur ce point sur leur s
capacitaire ce sont les préoccupations
dans le sénat m'a fait part aussi dans
votre commission m'a fait part aussi à
la fois sur les drones
moi j'ai pris les décisions et ce non
seulement j'ai été prise mais les deux
premiers drones et seront là à la fin de
cette année je sais mais je voudrais
simplement vous dire que les deux
premiers sont ils sont opérationnels à
niamey à la fin de cette année voilà
donc on peut discuter des décisions
enfin ils ont le mérite d'avoir été
prise était indispensable donc faudra
poursuivre tout au vent on aura
l'occasion de reparler des drones et
toute la problématique qu'il ya derrière
la fouace la génération là mais c'est la
génération qui suit la cyberdéfense sur
lesquels les travaux du sénat ont été
essentiels et vous voyez bien qu'il ya
là un sujet des des sujets majeurs et le
ravitailleur oui les mères étaient si
j'ai alors il faut être extrêmement
vigilant parce que c'est une
ce sont des choix qui ne sont pas
uniquement des des choix financiers les
financements sont là aussi le texte est
voté il sont ils sont mobilisables
mais il ya aussi des aspects techniques
que politiques qu'il faudra celui qu'il
faudra bien veiller
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre très
sincèrement